good morning everybody and welcome to
this latest meeting with the trafford
kobe 19 public engagement board
let's click that off the screen
um
thank you all for your attendance today
i don't have any apologies at all for
this meeting so smith move on swiftly
are there any declarations of interest
in any of the gender items this morning
and i don't see any there thank you
moving on to the minutes which i want to
take as read but i do want to include an
amendment to those minutes from the
meter from the last meeting for an
additional bullet point at 0.4
to read that the board were also advised
that trafford would be advising care
homes to restrict visits to care homes
in the borough by under 16 year olds
owing to the current high infection
rates amongst the four to
sixteen-year-old cohort with exceptions
to end-of-life visits or visits that
could be undertaken outdoors and that
this will be reviewed on the 1st of
november and
i will send to
committee services that that amendment
to the minutes and and the reason i
require that amendment
is because as chair i'm aware that the
local press
follow this meeting and i'm grateful of
the coverage that we received in
trafford as a result
that said i was disappointed following
the last meeting held on the 20th of
october to see headlines in the local
press and on social media that trafford
were banning visits to care homes in the
borough by under 16 year olds
now whilst i recognize headline cell
newspapers this was a blatant
misrepresentation of what was clearly
described as advice that trafford were
offering to care homes at a time that
our infection rates amongst our four to
16 year olds was exceptionally high
therefore can i ask of the press that
they accurately report this meeting and
if they have any questions as a result
of what they hear they please in future
either contact myself or the director of
public health for clarification
can i now take those minutes as a true
and accurate record with that amendment
thank you
uh that brings us unknown to item four
and we pass on to the current update on
the kovid 19 situation traffic from our
director of public health helen collins
good morning helen
morning thank you thanks chair um so
just an update on where we are currently
in trafford so you'll be really pleased
and relieved to know that our rates are
continuing to decline so we are at a
rate of
456.7 per hundred thousand and that's as
of the 29th of october
if you recall our peak on the 9th of uh
october we were at
846 so you know it's a really good
decline
um
and that for that figure for the weeks
seven days prior to the 29th we were at
1102 residents in traffic that tested
positive
uh the week before that our rate was at
five nine eight so it's been a really
nice steady decline
um far over 60s again it's still an area
that we are concerned about and our rate
is at 226
um per 100 000 so we are very much
watching our over 60s at the moment
um
we are 119th
nationally so we've gone from
the highest local authority to 119th but
i think as as good and as positive as
these figures are we need to be really
um measured in how we look at these
figures we're still above the england
average
um our hospital rates although they're
stable there is a very um slight
increase in admissions so we still need
to be watching these very carefully and
where we are at the moment at the
beginning of november
we're coming into winter pressures so
although you know it's a welcomed
decline in rates we still have to be
very careful
um in terms of positivity um
our positivity out in the community so
this is the percentage of people who go
for tests and then do test positive is
18
um but our overall positivity so we look
at people also going to hospital there
they're tested in a different airway
combined that our positivity rate is at
12 so that still is reasonably high and
that tells us there's still a lot of
infection circulating out in the
community
um in terms of how we sit with our gm
boroughs we do now actually look like we
do belong in gm in terms of rates
initially we were so far ahead of our
nearest um borough it was it was you
know really interesting to see that
difference but the moment we are
four per hundred thousand um higher than
the next borough which is reassuring for
us and the next borough down is very
so and our decrease has been a 23
decline within a week so you know this
is it's all looking good but again it's
just to reinforce that message that we
can't be complacent and we still have to
stay very committed to everything that
we're doing around covid
so on that note um as councillor freeman
spoke we did implement a pause in visits
for under 16s indoor care home visiting
for under 16s with some caveats attached
we did recommend the implementation of
face coverings for all staff in
education in early years and for pupils
in um secondary and that's kind of mask
on the move so not not when they're sat
down at their desks or not when they're
sat down eating but when they're moving
around
and
some other measures so the lfd testing
for household contacts as well we set a
review date of the 1st of november for
those and
the covert team we looked at those on
the first of november and we've agreed
to extend them until the 15th of
november and that is because of the the
where we sit nationally so we're like i
said previously we're above the national
average um and the hospital rates
although stable are increasing very
slightly so that is why we took that
decision and we'll be reviewing them
again on the 15th of november
um
the other things i just wanted to share
with you really is um there's been lots
of really interesting work ongoing
vaccination and rebecca demayne is
joining us today and kate murdoch is
joining us at 10 30. so kate is very
much involved in the 12 to 15 so can
help answer any questions and give you
an update there and rebecca will be able
to share some information around um
boosters and ongoing work and there's
some interesting work
with one of our large football teams as
well at the moment
community engagement is ongoing there's
a winter plan in place and danny can
share that with you again some fabulous
work that's going on in our community
and it's so important we've had lots of
really good feedback from health
visitors and gps about the importance of
actually
the messages that are going out into the
community and then how they resonate
into their settings as well
and then plan b
so um obviously there's been lots of
discussion around plan b
um at the moment plan b hasn't been
announced and we're not clear whether
plan b will be announced but um our
regulatory team are working incredibly
hard with those settings so some of our
rather large um
kind of events places our sporting
settings which we're very proud of in
trafford and our other large venues just
to make sure that they are prepared and
are aware of everything that they have
to put in place if
plan b is announced and of course we
don't know whether it will be at the
moment
and i think that's all our update at the
moment so thank you chair
thank you helen are there any questions
at all for helen
any hands up
nobody waving
thank you i don't see any therefore
we'll move on to the next item which is
the must testing ben good morning ben
good morning chair thank you um so i've
got a few updates today um and some key
messages to to pass on so in terms of
updates just a small one here will be
the form that the opening hours of our
local testing sites are now going to be
8 a.m till 6 p.m
rather than 8 00 20 p.m that's due to be
getting darker colder a few people
getting tested during that time period
so in traffic we've got two sites one
each other pack and one apartment will
be impacted by that
um otherwise we've not needed to do any
additional outbreak testing over the
past couple of weeks due to those rates
dropping but we have continued to
support businesses by handing out
lateral flow tests
and the engagement team will probably
cover this in their update but they've
also been giving out some key messages
when it comes to testing
now i mentioned at the last public
engagement board about the issue with a
pci lab in wolverhampton giving out a
number of negatives that are actually
positives just to remind everyone the uk
health security agency have stated that
they believe this is the only issue and
therefore people should continue to get
that confirmatory pcr
the reason why i bring this up um is
that the area predominantly affected was
the southwest um and that has that since
saw a large rise in covert rates
and essentially this is evidence that
testing works because we now know what
happens when that test system breaks
down in a particular location
so with that in mind our key testing
message is to avoid complacency keep
testing for example with pupils we know
that testing will probably have dropped
off over that half-term period so please
encourage secondary school people to
keep testing and that message applies to
everyone else as well winter is coming
we know there'll be lots more social
engagements so please pick up some
electrical flow tests and also if you've
got any symptoms please please please do
get yourself a pcr test however mild or
symptoms may be because as has been
shown in that case in wolverhampton
testing really really does work so we
really want to kind of hammer that
having that message home with with the
winter period coming up and that's all
from me chair
thank you any questions at all for uh
for ben
i don't see any thank you ben uh that
brings us then on to um
contact tracing and outbreak management
welcome kirsty
thank you good morning
and
so obviously schools were on half term
last week so we had a pretty quiet week
last week with obviously the case rates
declining alongside that
but since returning after half term
we've had a number of cases reported um
across our schools
we have no schools currently meeting
outbreak thresholds so we have 12
primary schools that currently have
cases in them but none are outbreak
thresholds and we have seven high
schools that currently have cases in
them
but no
outbreaks in any of those at the minute
um
throughout the last term uh 44 schools
met thresholds for eight breaks and we
worked really closely with those schools
holding either outbreak meetings or
undertaking risk assessments with them
to put any enhanced measures in place
and we didn't need to
um from a public health perspective
advise any children be sent home for
remote learning
them enhance measures
manage to reduce
the case rates within those schools to a
reasonable level
so we continue to support our schools in
early year settings we're running things
like regular q a sessions with them um
and just just keeping in close contact
with them on a daily basis
we've also got an online reporting form
for schools now that just provides them
with some ease of access for reporting
cases into us and that's working really
well
then in terms of workplaces and events
workplace activities really steady at
the minute so we've got around 23
workplaces workplace settings with cases
in them most workplaces just with one or
two cases reported so workplaces are
very much on board and kind of um
you know put stop that transmission um
through the work that we've done with
them in the past
and we are continuing to monitor the
events across trafford and when we've
got low numbers of cases in proportion
to the number of people attending those
events
and then with regards to our locally
supported contact racing so that's the
cases that trafford follow-up that the
national team haven't managed to reach
within 24 hours so that remains good um
last week
we followed up 164 cases with a
successful contact rate of 70 percent
and 55
we managed to fully complete contact
racing with them
we are currently the third highest in
greater manchester for successful
contact and completion of contact
tracing with people
and a further enhancement to that is
this week we've set up a dedicated phone
line for the contact racing team which
means that our residents will be
contacted from an all one six one number
and also residents can call us back on
that number and come straight through to
a contact tracing agent
and so even though it's really early
days of that implementation we have
managed to reach 100 of
people this week um using that that
local contact number
that's it from me um thank you
thank you i've got a question from
council racchinola council strike an old
place uh it might be something that's
been covered before but what is the
threshold for our um
outbreak level what is it
so
it typically obviously
it depends on the size of the school the
size of the class but we kind of go off
five cases
of people who have mixed closely in
transmission within a 10 day period or
10 of a year group
in terms of special schools and that
fresh art
early year settings where there's lower
class numbers
and we'll use a threshold of two cases
thank you
thank you any further questions at all
for kirsty
i don't see any thank you very much
curse it was very very useful
information
moving on then to mass vaccination and
rebecca
thank you very much chair um and good
morning everybody um
so i will give an update on the kind of
key um changes and updates since the um
last meeting i attended apologies i
didn't make the last one unfortunately
i've not got the up-to-date data
available today a national um issue with
regards to um a data lag and some data
quality issues at the moment
bearing in mind the number of new
cohorts that have come on board and the
difference between a third dose and a
booster dose is there's quite a lot of
data quality issues in the system so
rather than present out of date days so
i'll present a full update um next time
if that's okay chair
so in terms of um key updates um
obviously the booster program um
commenced uh
back in september
and the booster program did come with
some
questions around access i know we've
discussed this before because um there
is a national text which invites
people to book through the national
booking line um through um identified
sites but patients are also being called
in by their gp when they are
eligible for their covered booster six
months after the second dose that still
remains the position so there are still
two access points and again the message
is please um when invited do book your
um
booster as soon as you're eligible um
but there is also that um option to be
um invited in by your gp
there has been some confusion this week
because there's been a national
announcement about walk-ins for boosters
which came as some surprise to all of us
um and just to um
reiterate the traffic position at the
moment there are no trafford sites
offering walk-ins for boosters it's an
appointment only um system at the moment
and that's because of the governance
around it and um
the systems and and
people's eligibility
we do know that some individuals have
been turning up particularly to our
pharmacy sites and and
um asking for a booster without an
appointment and again just in terms of
messages just want to be really clear
that that's not currently available at
our trafford sites it is um appointment
based so if you could support with that
message because i think some of the
pharmacists have been feeling a little
under pressure um and as i say the the
national announcement um came as a
surprise to all of us
and the booster program is on track
we've got approximately 92 um eligible
at 92 i wish 92 000 eligible individuals
um in trafford and we're moving through
those eligible um patients at pace
there was a regional ambition to have
offered the
booster vaccination to all our old adult
care home staff and residents by the 1st
of november
we nearly made that we just had one home
that was
delivered to yesterday on the 2nd of
november and another home delivered to
today which is the 3rd of november but
again across the board really really
good um delivery for that gm ambition of
all older adult care homes and we're now
working um on the uh working age adult
homes as well so predominantly our
learning disability and mental health
homes is another vulnerable cohort so
they're um being scheduled this week
um in terms of 12 to 15s i know we've
got um kate joining at 10 30.
um so i'll i'll let kay give the update
on the 12 to 15 healthy um children
vaccination program but just to confirm
that we do have um provision available
from today now in trafford for healthy
12 to 15 year olds through the national
bookings
service which is at reed's pharmacy the
1881 building in ernst and we're
expecting more sites to come on board um
in terms of being able to offer an
out-of-school provision to healthy 12 to
15 year olds but again i'll let kate
talk in a little bit more detail about
the school-based um service
and and that's pretty much where we're
up to with covid unless anybody's got
any questions happy to take them
thank you rebecca any questions at all
we seem to be moving swiftly through
this agenda this morning um
so
no questions from anybody at all oh yes
sorry dorothy first dorothy evans please
thank you
yeah it's just
excuse me it's a question about a choice
in terms of the the the jab people have
had uh one jab the original jab and i
believe that people are now being
offered a different
job for the booster and there is um some
concern
around that can we give any assurances
that um there may be choice down the
line
[Music]
no the booster program is pfizer only
there is no choice in terms of um the
vaccination that you get as booster so
um again that's a really important
message
and that's based on the kind of
effectiveness of the fisa dose and the
the levels of immunity that it gives so
there's the national protocol around
that and unfortunately we can't
vary away from that
thank you
are there any further questions at all
well we'll we'll wait for k for but in
the meantime we'd better move on to
community engagement and i'll invite
danny to address us thank you danny
thanks chair good morning and so yeah
we've had three engagement sessions in
old trafford
and completing surveys with the
residents who have not yet had the
colgate vaccine
and in those three sessions we've spoke
to four to six people
who complete the questionnaires
and in the coming weeks we'll have five
more sessions planned so there's going
to be two in old trafford uh one in sale
and two in partington
and there's also an online survey which
gps have sent out as well
and that's complementing our
face-to-face work as well and we've not
had such a good up in that as of monday
there was one uh response in that survey
and but we're also using our
face-to-face work to relay key messages
to uh residents as well
um as ben briefly touched upon before
and if we speak to somebody
who's
reported that they've been vaccinated
and then we'll mention the importance of
testing as well just to get that message
out that even though they've been
vaccinated it's still important that
they're testing
and we've also had two briefing sessions
last week with our community champions
and angela from public health was there
as well and we had some productive
discussions
about how the program's running so far
and how we can make improvements as well
um
some of the things that came back from
the meetings was and the information
that the champion would like to receive
and ways that we can recruit more
champions as well
and from those discussions we've already
started to follow up on these as well
um we set up a couple of focus groups as
well um one's running with locals and
partington
and the other will be in traffic with
the traffic hong kongers group who are
based in sale
and from these focus groups we want to
generate discussions around how coal
continues to affect people
and how people currently feeling
and so this could be about people being
around others again and balancing being
safe and cold safe with lives returning
to some sense of normality as well and
finally we're continuing to get messages
out to our networks and we're building
this into our calendar events
and that will link to existing events
and community groups
and that's our update yeah
thank you danny i noticed you just
mentioned about the focus groups uh just
a quick question really from me um have
we any specific programs to take account
of the um
uh the number of people that have come
into the borough uh we've got obviously
some from hong kong that have come in uh
over the last few few months and also
we've got some uh afghan refugees as
well are we are we taking into account
these and getting them uh
vaccinated
uh helen do you want to answer
yeah so in terms sorry danny um
danny's team has been doing lots of work
around a lot of the new kind of arrivals
into the to the um borough but
specifically around the um resettlement
of afghan
refugees um that is being done at a
national level so people are being
ensured that they have their health
screen and their vaccine as soon as they
arrive so that isn't a locality issue
thank you are there any other
are there any other questions to talk
about in cancer acting
yeah i'm just wondering all the work
that's being done to try and get
the people who've not been vaccinated uh
vaccinated um
you know what what the impact
has been in relation to that uh you know
have you sort of tracked whether
you know
it has been effective
all that work
yeah um thank you councillor so the um
helen briefly touched on an apologies i
should have given an update in my um
last briefing so we um have done a piece
of work and implemented a scheme uh
we've been able to access some contained
funding to
do a real deed dive into those
individuals that we recognize through
primary care who have not had their
first dose but
neither have they had a decline marked
on their record so that started a couple
of weeks ago across four practices in
the north
due to half term last week and the
number of people being off we've not yet
had the feedback in terms of how many
numbers so and that has been um put in
place this week so we've asked all of
the practices to give us an update on
numbers and the impact and get some case
studies as well so we get some anecdotal
feedback about why they might have um
not had their first dose before and and
had that now so um
i don't have the numbers with me today
but we will certainly get that for next
time
yeah
thanks for that because i think that'd
be really useful
thank you
thanks rebecca any further questions at
all we got to half past 10 helen
i think you've got three minutes can i
just make a point um
sorry i did put it in the chat and it
was something that dorothy raised and i
think it's really important that we just
um recognizing people may be anxious
about having their booster vaccine
because of you know the different range
of vaccines available but it's
incredibly important that people do
get their boosted vaccine
and they get that protection from um the
virus that they require
um
if there are any particular concerns
directly that you're hearing out in the
community or any of the counsellors are
hearing any worries that people have
about the booster please do get in touch
then we can work with our community
engagement team of comms teams and do
some targeted work out into particular
communities if there are any concerns
but the message is if you're invited
please do go and have your vaccine it's
really important thank you
there is a further question there from
from andrew can i just check if there's
a clear message we can provide the
public around compatibility of the fisa
booster with the oxford vaccine if
that's what people received for the
first and second
doses yes i think we can do some
specific messaging can't we about both
concerns around the booster and also
about why pfizer has been chosen as the
third and i'll take we'll take those
onto our comms team i think it's an
important message and good to hear that
feedback
thank you
so i just want that communication that
you know um simple language and in other
languages as well
i'm just going to keep banging that drum
that's fair enough absolutely right and
we'll take that on board thank you
council racking ola
so we're now just waiting for
has it gone off next two minutes still
to go
um
no one's got any further questions at
all for
can i just ask um because i i live in
old trafford um on ayers road and danny
was saying that they've been out and met
people and groups could have just
started with a target in those who were
known not to be vaccinated or were they
just knocking on random doors
it was
opportunistic so it was a street based
engagement
um
no no door knocking so just going up to
people on the street just having general
conversations and just sort of
introducing the conversation around
covid
and if they've had the vaccine and as
kind of said before if they've had the
vaccine then
they were completing the full
questionnaire but that's when we were
trying to introduce all the messages as
well just so it wasn't just a person
that would just let them get on the way
so i was introducing messages as well
and then if they hadn't been vaccinated
then we were inviting them to complete
the survey as well
okay cheers
i'm still waiting for kate um
can i just go back to
the report helen that you produced as
part of the papers where we obviously we
still got this um
concerns around the uptake in vaccine
particularly in the north um of the
borough um how concerned are we and and
are we obviously clearly we're still
doing work to to encourage people to get
vaccinated but is there more that
possibly we could be doing
uh rebecca um so
from us from um public health obviously
the inequalities are a concern and what
we're aware of some of our communities
is the low uptake in the 12 to 15s
is then mirrored in the household and
then we would see that transmission
through the household um and we've got a
brilliant team that rebecca works with
and colleagues beanish for example who
you know forensically know the data and
know which communities have got low
uptake
um so we are doing rebecca so we're
doing a piece of work in the north which
is targeting uh people aged over 60 who
haven't formally declined but do not
have a record of vaccination on their
medical records and we're having a
direct conversations by the clinician to
um this individual so brilliant really
brilliant targeted pieces of work are
ongoing at the moment um
i would say we know where the concerns
are and as a
system we're working
at lots of different levels there's not
one single kind of answer to
to increasing uptake there's lots of
different kind of approaches it's those
clear communication messages
accessibility um and appropriateness of
the vaccine as well that often acts as a
barrier
rebecca i don't know if you wanted to
add anything
thanks helen uh probably not much to add
i think
across the board and across all our
partners we've done a lot of work um i
think bearing in mind the question that
counselor asked shortly uh
not long ago about the impact of the
additional work that we're doing in the
north will then perhaps present to us
some as i say the feedback that we get
some other um messaging that we can try
so we might get some examples and
stories from people who give us reasons
why they've declined or reasons why they
haven't um stepped forward so i think
that might give us something else to go
at
but i'm not sure that there's a much
more we can do i think as helen said we
know where the areas are we know some of
the reasons
and
at a point in time if people flatly
refuse then you know people will refuse
and so
we we continue to do all the work that
we're doing it hasn't stopped and it
won't stop this is now an evergreen
offer as you know so it will this is
almost becoming it doesn't feel like it
almost becoming business as usual and
we'll be an annual and so that evergreen
offer remains and therefore the activity
that we do remain so
yeah thank you i have a question from
councillor blackburn
uh thank you um
if after 18 months if certain
individuals have not taken up the offer
of of jobs
should our resources be refocused
because is it realistically likely that
they're going to take up jumps if they
haven't over all this time just thinking
about if if if our resources need to be
refocused then
um you know in order to in order that
those that maybe need extra help who
have had jobs can you know can be um
you know can be sort of contacted and
interacted with
yeah i think that's a really valid point
as i say it's an evergreen offer now so
where our resource needs to be will be
dependent on where uptake is and where
hesitancy is and what different cohorts
will come on board so we're doing that
to some extent
already so we've we've shifted resources
for example to the younger age groups
where the younger population has come on
board and we've shifted resources to
school so we will continue to do that
and that's part of our ongoing review of
the programme and i've just seen a
question in the chat as well about um
vaccinations to be done at home so we do
have a vaccination offer at home for
housebound patients or patients who um
are identified as housebound and we also
put some additional support into people
at home with um
additional needs again mental health and
ld so we do have an offer um for people
who have um you know the issues which
might prevent them going to a
vaccination clinic
but we need to be careful that we get
the balance right in terms of our
resources as well and clinicians that
can vaccinate and you know it needs to
be managed
thank you rebecca um we've now been
joined by kate murdock welcome kate
so can we hand over to you to give us
the update on the 12 to 15
um
vaccination program thank you
good morning everybody um
thanks for inviting me to join so we are
um as you know well
started in fact we are
probably about three quarters of the way
through our schools in trafford and i
think comparably we're doing really well
and our uptake um has been very variable
across the the schools as we expected
and we're not entirely sure why
uptake has been
you know parents are refusing it because
we haven't been able to look at that
data
and but we are working our way through
our schools and
the program is scheduled to be complete
in trafford and the offer is being made
to all settings and the program will be
complete by the end of november
um
and we are just working with the
remaining settings just around the
consent process and getting as many
young people consented as possible
so we have got
about i think just off the top of my
head i think we're in one school today
so by the end of the day i think we will
have five mainstream high schools left
to complete and then our specialist
provision that we're working very
closely with
[Music]
thank you kate um just just a quick
question from me
clearly we've had a lot of
children in the cohort have had have
contracted covid
there is obviously a time delay then
between that when they've finished uh
the infections cleared to when they can
have the um the vaccination and are we
are we getting that information out and
across and and are we are we publicizing
what the worship program will be for
those that missed out at school because
they were had covered or were off
isolating
yeah yeah i think that's a really valid
point chair thanks for raising it we
have been quite significantly impacted
in some schools and because of the
numbers of young people who have got a
current culprit infection or have had it
in the last 28 days all of our
communications to parents very clearly
state that they can't have the vaccine
within 28 days of a positive test we are
still receiving a lot of consent for
children that do fall into that remit
and we screen them out obviously and we
are communicating
um
you for example the school we were in
yesterday and we've sent a communication
to that school that can be sent out to
parents which gives them the booking
link so they can access the community
and the mass vaccine offer that's now
coming online um for
for the 12 to 15 year olds to access
that when they are able to so all of
that information is in the comments that
we're sending out
thank you other council blackman do you
have a question because your hands still
raised yes please couldn't just ask um
have we had any feedback at all from the
secondary age pupils who've had covered
about any of their experiences or
or
their take on whether or not
um
they would want to have um the job or
not
um we certainly haven't done that piece
of work because obviously we've had to
implement the vaccine program at pace
with
sort of fairly restricted resource so
unfortunately we haven't but that's
certainly something
and that we could potentially consider
with our community engagement team
around some work with with unimmunised
cohorts to understand their reasons why
and if there's anything that would
would help them to access the vaccine
moving forward
thank you okay uh counselor knowledge
you have a question
no it's just a legacy hand are there any
further questions at all for kate
i don't cindy kate can i thank you for
coming on that short
to give us this update it's been very
very useful thank you
um
is there any other business at all this
morning
i don't see any so thank you again kind
of thank you all for your attendance our
next meeting will be on the 17th of
november at 10 a.m and by that time
hopefully our infection rate will be
even lower let's keep our fingers
crossed can i just conclude by again
thanking all of our public health staff
uh all of our engagement teams for the
work that they're doing right across
trafford i know it's been a really
difficult period the last few weeks
particularly for you
with where we went with the rate
but but thank you you know we really do
value the work that you're doing
and with that i wish you all a a
pleasant day thank you very much for
attending
thank you bye bye bye bye thank